hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast advancing metagenomic tools
for monitoring antibiotic resistance and
pathogen gene markers in water and the
environment it is presented by Amy
prudent PhD a professor of civil and
environmental engineering and associate
dean and director of interdisciplinary
graduate education at Virginia Tech I am
Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Putin I will
now turn the presentation over to her
thank you so much for the introduction
and it's really a pleasure to be
virtually with you all today and we'll
take some time and think about a
tremendous problem of antibiotic
resistance that we're facing as a
society think about it particularly from
a water and environment perspective and
think about the role of new tools in
next generation DNA sequencing and meta
genomics and how we can help us advance
monitoring and mitigation and inform
policy I do want to take a moment and
thank several research sponsors that
have helped us keep going to do this
work so some of its funded by the
National Science Foundation and their
partnership for international research
and education the water research from
the US Department of Agriculture and the
Alfred P sloan Foundation so as an
overview of what I hope to cover today
and about it resistance is a global
problem that requires global action and
we need to understand the factors that
contribute to the spread of antibiotic
resistance so that we can inform better
policy to control the spread of
antibiotic resistance and I think an
environmental perspective and really
enhance our ability to do that and there
are a lot of urgent research needs I
have a few listed here but in particular
I want to emphasize the need for
monitoring tools and monitoring tools
that advance our understanding of what
contributes to the spread of antibiotic
resistance monitoring tools that inform
risk assessment this is what helps us
predict how many people were animals
they become sick or ill or be affected
by the target that we're monitoring also
fate and transport modeling how things
will spread identifying hotspots where
maybe we should focus our mitigation so
it's important to take a moment and just
appreciate the gravity of the problem of
antibiotic resistance the Centers for
Disease Control in the US has estimated
that they're about 23,000 deaths per
year because of antimicrobial resistance
a very conservative estimate in the EU
it's about 25,000 deaths per year and in
India 58,000 newborns alone die from
sepsis each year and this O'Neil report
out of the UK has got quite a bit of
attention and pretty
think that a year 2050 deaths from
antibiotic resistance will likely
surpass those of cancer and so for these
reasons we see the World Health
Organization really taking a leading
role and calling for urgent and
coordinated action or else we're going
to be headed for a post-antibiotic era
so we've come to rely on antibiotics to
cure a variety of infections and once
again these infections can come back to
haunt us if we don't do something about
this problem I also wanted to highlight
action from the United Nations and point
out that this is actually an initiative
from their environmental subgroup so the
frontiers emerging issues of implemental
concern when they met last fall they
identified antibiotic resistance as
their top grand environmental challenge
and this is a key figure from that
report and notice how they emphasized
water as a common thread linking various
sources of inputs of both antibiotics
and antibiotic resistant bacteria into
the environment so of course a
substantial portion of antibiotics is
used in livestock and of course in
people and where does that end up it
ends up excreted so that will contain
both antibiotics that are unmetabolized
it will also contain bacteria that maybe
have been selected in the gut for
resistance and so even with some level
of treatment you're going to have our
water environment influenced and then
that can ultimately be a specific alert
to people via recreation or because that
water is used as a source water for our
drinking water treatment and right now
this is really an issue that's not
really addressed in our current water
regulations also wanted to highlight the
National Action Plan for combating
about it resistant bacteria and this has
been moving forward and has really
provided a framework for addressing the
issue in the u.s. at a national scale
and it calls for what is called a one
health perspective so that's where you
consider people animals and the
environment together as integrated
systems and that we need to understand
on as a whole in order to understand the
root causes of antibiotic resistance and
how it spreads and in this guidance it's
I like that whole genome sequencing
metagenomics bioinformatics approaches
are going to be key to advancing
understanding and addressing this issue
and it's also emphasized that it's very
much an international problem that
requires international attention and
Calabrian here I just wanted to
highlight that as part of this national
strategy the US Centers for Disease
Control have definitely been following
up on this one health perspective and
currently they're looking to fund
several research proposals on this topic
and many of them deal with wastewater
reclaimed water and drinking water so I
want to spend some time and talk a bit
about water where our water comes from
at the tap so it comes from the
environment surface water groundwater is
taken in by the drinking water treatment
plant and it's typically you settle out
the particles you filter it you add
chlorine or I mean some disinfectant and
then you deliver it to households
buildings institutions through the water
distribution system now we may not think
about it but it may take some days to
make it through the several miles of
pipes into our home so water quality can
change during that time and within the
home once it crosses that dashed line
onto the pretty there's a lot of
conditions with
in a building that can encourage
microbial growth so you've got warm
temperatures you've got stagnation times
while you're sleeping or work and high
stars area to volume ratio and so
thinking about the water environment
where this water may come from in the
first place and influences this is a
fate diagram thinking about ways that we
know antibiotic resistance can spread
and ways that we think it might spread
so thicker arrows at the top we know
there's person to person spread
sometimes animal to person but here at
the bottom are more hypothetical
pathways we have measured markers of
resistance in the water environment
associated with runoff from agricultural
fields where there's been application of
manure and residuals and likewise
downstream of wastewater treatment
plants they're not really designed to
address antibiotic resistance at this
point and so you can see markers in
affected waterways in our work we've put
an emphasis on the antibiotic resistance
genes or Arg s as our so called
pollutant sub interest so in
environmental sciences we think about
and track pollutants of interest so
pathogens themselves that cause disease
can be thought of as pollutants but in
the case of antibiotic resistance we
know that the DNA that causes resistance
these AR G's can be shared among
bacteria so bacteria can do things like
conjugation there's transduction that's
mediated by viruses and transformation
bacteria can even take up DNA from dead
bacteria and express that and so this
means that the AR G's transcend their
host and so if we really want to track
the spread of antibiotic resistance it
makes sense to focus on AR G's
here at the bottom I also point out that
it makes sense to focus on mobile
genetic elements or mtv's because those
are pieces of DNA that helped bacteria
to share genes like each other
now I mentioned risk assessment is
important to keep in mind because this
is how we will down the numbers and
figure out where we should focus our
attention where are people likely to get
sick how many they forget levels of
antibiotic resistant bacteria of what
type or what levels of antibiotic
resistance genes would we need to
achieve to protect the public
as for led by Nick Asheville and
colleagues was really the first of its
kind to lay out a framework for
achieving this it is complex and it's
different than typical risk assessment
and on the next slide I've broken down
why that is I've taken that figure and
was rated some key concepts so you have
a or G's you have pieces of DNA you have
antibiotics metals selective agents and
then these can be taken up they can
exert selection on here I've called them
environmental antibiotic resistant
bacteria so maybe not necessarily ones
that cause disease but they can carry
the Arg s and what we directly worry
about human health is pathogenic a or
B's or PA RVs and so we can have up take
a mutation and a human gut that we
cannot happening in the environment and
an animal so one health so in any of
these environments there's an
opportunity for gene exchange and
pathogenic strains of a or B's to
develop and so then we think about
exposure in humans and animals and
transfer environment ultimately what our
risk would be modeling is a treatment
failure in patients so that you take
antibiotics to get better you get better
and we've also worked on that within my
community of the association of
environmental and Riaan science
professors we had a workshop and further
elaborated on this framework and
Professor Chuck Haas at Drexel
University played a key role in
developing this schematic of basically
starting to model how a our Gees move
between humans animals and the
environment and here at Virginia Tech
we've been working particularly on
recycled water systems so we're very
interested and what happens when we
flush water down the drain that may
contain excreted antibiotics and
resistant bacteria they go to that
wastewater treatment plant that wwt pee
and there's treatments there that purify
the water remove pathogens remove
organic carbon but again they're not
specifically designed to remove and
about it resistant bacteria or energies
and so we're interested in if this could
be an issue for Public Health
and keep in mind we use this kind of
water for non potable reuse so
irrigating crops things like that
recreational fields but we're also using
advanced technologies and maybe even
extreme treatments like rice osmosis
which very few things can get through
that kind of membrane it's a treat it's
very expensive but it's effective and
you have a very pure water product and
so that tends to be used when there's a
direct potable reuse of that water so
that's to say we're very interested in
understanding how different water
treatments control the kinds of microbes
that are at the point of use whether
people are exposed to the water from
drinking it or inhaling aerosols or
recreation etc so we've put forth this
concept of what we call an expose ohm so
considering full sources of exposure
I wanted to make sure folks were aware
of this exciting initiative called the
Global Water pathogens project and this
has been led by Professor John Rose at
Michigan State University basically in a
catalog all the genes that are out there
and update what we know about the link
between sanitation and public health and
what various treatments do to remove
various pathogens and I had the honor to
co edit the bacteria chapter with
Professor Nick cash bolt and dr.
Jennifer Miller so I just found a circle
in addition to several chapters on
various pathogens we were able to write
a chapter together on antimicrobial
resistance as kind of a next generation
concern in sanitation and hygiene and
Public Health and in this chapter we
have very extensive tables an explosion
of research out there in logging the
kinds of antibiotic resistance genes and
resistant bacteria that occur in various
environments and what the effects of
various treatments are and so this is
substantial progress but I think what we
need moving forward is taking this
information and translating it to
hazards and risk and also understanding
mechanisms rates of antimicrobial
resistance spread and models so that we
can focus where we invest our resources
to fighting this problem in terms of
where to monitor we tend to look at a
background so it is important to
recognize that there are toll occurring
forms of antibiotic resistance and so
when you're monitoring you need some
representative background or control to
have a sense of what the baseline is
otherwise you might just analyze a
sample in isolation and think
no there's a RGS here we've got a
problem well not necessarily we need to
understand which patterns and types of
energies present a problem in a risk and
when we do monitoring we want to be able
to assess whether weather mitigation
strategies are working we want to be
able to identify hot spots where
antimicrobial resistant bacteria are
most likely to evolve share their genes
and spread and guide investment and so
I'm lighting here our project funded by
the National Science Foundation the
halting environmental antibiotic
resistance dissemination project so this
is led by my colleague professor peter
vickers 'land
and so we're looking at all these
sources to wastewater treatment plants
in it and we're doing an international
survey and this next slide highlights
some of our partners internationally so
we've been sending students to places
like India us Switzerland Sweden
Philippines and Hong Kong and basically
surveying the occurrence of antibiotic
resistance genes and so we have partners
at University of Michigan and at Rice
and at Buffalo and internationally in
China Hong Kong the Philippines India
Sweden Switzerland and Portugal and this
slide shows our sampling points so we
look at what's going into the wastewater
treatment plant
what is in the activated sludge basement
and that's where you actually have your
good microbes that are very actively
growing and metabolizing and breaking
down waste and then we look at what
comes out of the secondary clarifier so
that's relatively clean water that's
typically disinfectant and so then you
have the final effluent that's a clean
disinfected water that's ready to be
discharged to some sort of receiving
body so typically that might be a river
a stream and so in that case we sample
upstream
so here are results and an example of
what we see when we apply shock and meta
genomic DNA sequencing to wastewater
treatment plant samples and at the top
we're just looking at the raw sewage to
all of these wastewater treatment plants
that we sampled in our international
survey and when we look at total AR G's
we call it the resist ohm so any DNA
sequence that gets a hit in the database
as being similar to an antibiotic
resistance gene and it can classify them
as you see here on the right we saw
various causes of antibiotic resistance
genes ranging from aminoglycoside like a
peptide multi drug tetracycline etc and
so the top story here when we look at
the raw sewage at the top and we rank it
by abundance of totally or G's there's a
striking pattern where did we see the
highest numbers in Hong Kong and India
where did we see the lowest numbers in
Sweden and we know that Sweden is
extremely proactive and we're really
among the first countries to restrict
antibiotic use and take measures to deal
with antibiotic resistance so this is a
sign that those kinds of policies can
work where is it the extreme India and
parts of Asia have kind of been in the
spotlight in terms of lacks controls on
antibiotic use and where we're seeing
some of the new resistant strains of
pathogens arise on the bottom we're
looking at the treated with water and
similarly ranked and showing that
overall there can be some removal but
it's modest and what we see more of than
removable is a shift in the resistant
the kinds of resistance and and so this
tells us that we need to kind of
understand what are the metrics for
telling us
there's risk so again it's not
necessarily just the AR G's are there
but it's it's the types and their
occurrence patterns so I want to talk a
little bit about our survey of recycled
or reclaimed water distribution systems
so this is where you take tray take
highly dated wastewater and then you
distribute it through a distribution
system if it's recycled water it
typically goes through a purple pipe if
it's non potable and again you need a
control environment to compare to so we
wanted to see if there were markers of
AR G's and reclaimed water that were
maybe a concerned and so the control
environment we chose to compare to is
your typical potable water so is there
anything different about reclaimed water
versus of potable water and we looked at
the point of entry
so that's your freshly treated water and
we looked at the point of use that's
water after it's been through miles and
miles of distribution and maybe the
water quality has changed at that point
of use and we emphasize the importance
of looking at the point of use because
where there's the potential for human
exposure and so here are some results
from that survey which were recently
published in environmental science and
technology here are the several classes
of antibiotic resistance genes that we
identified from the meta sequencing and
these are in log gene copies per
milliliter here's our drinking water
results and the challenge here was that
it was difficult to get enough DNA to do
this analysis in the drinking water so
it was hard to compare to our recycled
water samples here but some take homes
were that the profiles were different
where we were able to do comparison
types and relative numbers of energies
were different totall erred
were not significantly different so it's
not like they were off the chart in the
reclaimed water but we did have low
statistical power to contend and we
didn't see the total a or G's increasing
from point of entry to point of views at
least on the total basis we also used
quantitative polymerase chain reaction
or PCR to complement our metagenomic
sequencing and this is useful because it
is really precise has a very low
detection limit and so you man on some
key markers and so here we looked at
cell one self and amid resistance genes
because our prior work has shown that
these tend to be strongly correlated
with human sources we've looked at
vancomycin Quindlen and beta lactam
states because we know those correspond
to antibiotics that are really important
to human health and then at the bottom I
point out that we looked at mobile
genetic elements again not technically
our G but the in Taiwan class one
integrand is strongly correlated with
human sources of antibiotic resistance
genes and multi-drug resistance so
general take-home messages here were
that all the reclaimed water did have
higher so long games for the Quinlan and
beta lactam resistance if they were high
air in either water they were higher in
the reclaimed water there was no
difference in DNA and this in Taiwan
gene was a good indicator in terms of
the reclaimed water having higher levels
in all cases we did some correlation
analyses to get a sense of what might be
contributing to the patterns that we saw
so for sure that gentle microbial
community composition plays a big role
and this has been seen in other work so
that's inherited resistance from mother
to daughter cell we saw correlations
with antibiotics that we measured in the
water as well as heavy
metals both of these can place selection
pressure on resistant bacteria and other
things that people might not think about
but biodegradable organic carbon and
phosphorous in the water which are going
to be higher in reclaimed water is also
correlated with AR DS a bit of good news
is that we actually saw a negative
corazon with chlorine in the reclaimed
water so this suggests that it's it's
doing its job to kill off bacteria and
and that includes resistant bacteria but
I'd emphasis it emphasize that there is
work going on in this area of how to
optimize the chlorination because in
some situations it looks like it could
select for resistant bacteria so we need
to understand how to optimize that this
is some work that we did on direct
potable reuse so this is a situation
where you actually intend to drink the
treated reclaimed water so you treat it
to a high standard usually with reverse
osmosis is there a membrane Dignan which
removes virtually everything from the
water there's a few things that can get
through but that's very expensive and
energy intent intensive and so folks are
looking at what is the optimal treatment
and so here we looked at several
different waters that were treated to
direct potable reuse standards and
consider the scenario where you might
blend it with your traditional potable
water source and incubated it and pipes
for a few weeks to see what tends to
grow in the biofilm and the bulk water
and this is a project that was sponsored
by the water Research Foundation and
Andy Salveson ocurro
engineers was the PI on this and here
are some key results for this study
basically we saw with the red bars that
yes bacteria did grow in these waters
and the pipes while they were incubated
that's not a surprise anywhere you have
water and a surface
you'll get microbes but markers of ones
that could be of concern so Legionella
mycobacteria Pseudomonas aeruginosa are
opportunistic pathogens that are more
difficult role in water distribution
systems because they can grow in biofilm
in certain situations so we looked at
markers of those with qpcr and we didn't
see any alarming levels to situations we
had non detect and we also looked at
antibiotic resistance genes in the in
Taiwan class one integrand and those
also tended to be very low so I think
this is encouraging that you know if we
do treat water to a very high standard
that we can remove these markers of
concern but you know this is just one
study it was eight weeks so you know
more work can be done to optimize this
so stepping back and thinking about the
big picture I talked about a one health
framework there's also this concept of a
one water framework and it really is
strongly applicable to the issue with AR
G's and so this is a study that we
published in collaboration with several
international scientists that are also
working on this issue so we had a
roundtable discussion at the
environmental dimension of antibiotic
resistance conference that was held at
Michigan State University last August
and published this paper in Femmes
microbiology ecology and basically
highlighting all of the opportunities
that we can put up barriers in our water
sanitation systems to the spread of
antibiotic resistance and so this was
based on a consensus discussion at that
conference and just basic things like
having a sanitation system which doesn't
happen in all parts of the world to how
we treat the water and and depending on
how we use the water optimizing that but
we keep coming back to this issue of
what to monitor we don't have a standard
target of what to monitor for
antimicrobial resistance so for fecal
pathogens in general we tend to monitor
eco liable forms they themselves aren't
necessarily pathogens but it's an
indication that a water is impaired so
is there something similar for
antimicrobial resistance and we see a
lot of different methods I highlighted a
few so far I showed you the shotgun
metagenomic approach and qPCR you could
also culture resistant bacteria the
various targets and the point is that
each of these methods using it's a
different perspective on the proverbial
elephant
antimicrobial resistance behavior in the
environment and what we really need is
an integrated understanding so
especially in a research application as
we're trying to understand the problem
and inform policy we need to understand
the whole elephant
we need a mechanistic perspective and we
need a microbial ecological perspective
so just looking at one microbe at a time
one pathogen at a time isn't going to
get us that big picture and we need
something that that's informative risk
assessment and fate and transport models
and at this point I think it's fair to
say we have a good handle on what we
call a hazard identification but we need
to move forward in terms of developing
specific numbers and risks so some
things to think about in terms of
monitoring and risk assessment for
antimicrobial resistance in the
environment there are some initiatives
so the World Health Organization and
others are looking at E coli because
that's something that's fairly
straightforward to monitor most labs
even the Simpson do that and specific
specifically the extended spectrum beta
lactamase coli and then there's PCR and
meta genomics to get more of a microbial
ecological perspective I'm so in an
ideal you can do all of these but with
metagenomics in particular we are
limited by bioinformatics lines so it's
a way to get tremendously rich
information I showed you some examples
but we need standardized ways to purpose
that information and in a way that's
comparable across different studies but
I'd bear in mind that even that and it
might boil down to a few different genes
that are really indicators of
antimicrobial resistance and horizontal
gene transfer potential so just like we
look at coliform zazen decay
Iko pathogens may be targets like the in
taiwan gene or the soul one gene are
indicators of human sources of
antibiotic resistance and so here are
several indicators that are being looked
at by the World Health Organization and
also in the EU and so there's a nice
review article by Brenda at all in
Nature Reviews that describes some
potential targets
so with shotgun metagenomic sequencing
which is derived from next-generation
DNA sequencing we have a real
opportunity to if we go deep enough to
get all of the DNA that's there and
directly interrogate it for the presence
of a orgies or what we call the resist
own but databases are emitted difficult
to know which a orgies are concerned and
of course with any DNA based method
there's always a question of viability
and functionality that we have to bear
in mind and it is a semi-quantitative
method so i'ma talk a little bit about
the pipelines that we've been developing
here at Virginia Tech and this is in
collaboration with dr. Lee Ching Jeong
and dr. Lenny Keith and Computer
Sciences and our students miss tavo men
and Hsiao have worked hard on moving
this forward it's an important so in
doing metagenomic analysis a critic
uestion to start with is what is an Arg
and so a common approach is to apply
highly stringent cut-offs so you compare
your DNA sequences with what's available
in the database and the idea is if
you're very stringent then if it's an
Arg it's really an Arg but the problem
is that can lead to false negatives and
so that would be like telling this
pregnant woman that she's not pregnant
that's a problem so likewise
we might back off and apply loser offs
and be less stringent but then that's
going to lead to false positives so
that's like telling this man that he's
pregnant and that's a problem too and so
that's where we've been developing an
alternative approach that's derived from
learning so we call this deep energy and
so here the pipeline is trained to learn
and recognize an energy and there's two
main advantages to the approach so one
is ideally you avoid this problem of
both false positives and false negatives
by having a very highly accurate means
to identify energy another advantage is
that you actually have the potential to
discover new AR G's and we demonstrated
this actually by taking these 76 novel
metallo beta lactamase genes that were
recently published by yo Keem Larson's
group in Sweden they worked very hard
using a functional meta nomic approach
and cloning to find new metallo beta
lactamase genes before they've ever been
observed or reported in the databases so
the idea is to be proactive and identify
genes before they're a concern and this
took them a long time to do this work
and with our deep Arg pipeline we were
actually able to identify 65 of these 76
novel teens in a very short time so we
thought that was pretty encouraging
there's still the issue though that the
databases are not fully updated and that
also takes time and people power so
we've developed an initiative called Arg
minor and this actually taps into
crowdsourcing to help curate the
database
and so this is available actually
through Amazon on MTurk and anybody can
contribute to this and what we found is
that you can train laypeople to curate
arg databases they actually in a
controlled study performed just as well
as experts the one thing you have to be
careful of is that you have to make sure
to identify potential spammers or lazy
people that are entering random input
but with proper training people can
correctly curate these energies and can
start to earn scores and rewards in the
system so it's kind of fun and you're
all encouraged and welcome to try this
out another tool that we have in the
works is what we're calling meta compare
and so this is a way to analyze a
metagenomic data set and not just
identify the arg s but also consider
whether they're present on a mobile
genetic element or in a human pathogen
and this is a framework that was
actually proposed by Jose Martinez's
group cyclic assumption that the AR G's
were most most concerned about are the
ones that are mobile and potentially in
a pathogen and so with the metagenomic
data we can actually a sell it and
predict whether this is the case and so
this is an example of what assembly and
network analysis looks like so you get a
sense of which genes occur on the same
segment in this example you see plasmid
highlighted in the middle so you can get
a sense if there are mobile genetic
elements and then this is an example of
what the meta compare validation looks
like so in panel a and the left is where
we just did a basic plot on three
dimensions of a or G's on the bottom
mobile genetic
mints on the right and pathogens on the
top we really don't see much of a
pattern but when we actually assemble
the data and apply the matter compare
algorithm to the three dimensional risk
space when we applied this to publicly
available data we saw very clear
patterns where the hospital sewage
actually scored the highest resistant
risk and the wastewater treatment plant
effluent the lowest and the farm
effluent in the middle now all of the
data I've shown so far is generated
using alumina based next-generation DNA
sequencing it's very powerful and you
can sequence very deep into metagenomes
but it's limited by very short reads
often 150 base pairs is on the long side
for this technology and that does limit
the confidence in assembly that you need
to do that you need for things like the
meta compare and so there are
third-generation DNA sequencing
technologies that are out there we've
been using the mini on sequencing and an
advantage of this is you get really nice
long strings of DNA sequences and so you
have much higher confidence in knowing
which energies occur together on the
same strand with mobile genetic elements
and pathogens but downside is that there
is a higher error rate and the
sequencing and we tend to get lower
coverage this is work that our research
scientist dr. dong grande has been
working on and so she's been looking at
some of these wastewater treatment plant
samples that we've collected as part of
your project and so here's four samples
she's looked at and you can see that
there there is a range of coverage and
that we get so that has to be taken into
account in the
but here's the beauty of the Nano for
sequencing we can I defy an Arg and then
we can look at the neighboring DNA and
have high confidence and who the host is
and that's what we're looking at here in
these four different samples and it's
definitely striking it jumps out at you
if you look at the names of the bacteria
they're identified on the neighboring
DNA a lot of these are associated with
known pathogens so as a sonido bacter
sudama's Vibrio Salmonella e.coli so
this is definitely a concern this is
preliminary data but it gives you an
idea of how you can use this tool to
track not only Arg s but their hosts and
keep an eye out on the horizon we have
another pipeline in the work called nano
ard which is similar to meta compare but
it's configured specifically to handle
these longer nanopore sequencing reads
and to look at the co-occurrence of
energies mobile elements and pathogens
and so in closing just to think about
what are the tools we have to monitor
energies in the environment how can they
guide us an investment of resources and
control and mitigation and so even if we
have all available information you know
we do shine metagenomic sequencing to a
hundred percent depth we still need ways
to interpret that deep that data and so
I've listed some ideas of what we might
focus on it could be the total numbers
of all a orgies but we see that doesn't
always have a striking pattern it did in
the sewage but not in the treated
effluent we could look at diversity of
the air
with the assumption that more different
types might present more different types
of risk may be important to a RGS like
those extended spectrum beta-lactam aces
and carp enemies 'as genes like the New
Delhi metallo beta lactamase so things
that we know are emerging in the clinic
and associated with very difficult to
treat infections we can look at energies
and mobile genetic elements we can focus
on energies associated with human or
anthropogenic sources acquired AR G's
energies encoding resistance to
important human antibiotics presence in
pathogen and in a viable host bacterium
so with that I I really thank you for
our time together today I hope that
found it worthwhile and enriching I
think our many funding sponsors and also
my team this was very much a
collaborative effort of a number of
scientists and engineers and students
that contributed to this work and these
are just a few and I'm really happy to
spend some time with you all and answer
any questions that you might have thank
you doctor prudent for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email let's get started
our first question is what kind of
evidence is there that antimicrobial
resistance is truly an environmental
problem and not just an issue of
infection control in hospitals that's a
really good question I think the number
one evidence is that we have invested a
lot
in infection control in hospitals and
the problem hasn't gone away and we see
a rise in what we call community
acquired infections so for example MRSA
in the US has been a big challenge in
terms of community acquired infections
so that's delving into the environment
and I think just the common sense we
have to follow where the antibiotics go
after we use them they are excreted by
humans and animals int environment along
with the resistant bacteria and
everything that we know about what
happens when you have pathogens and
resistant bacteria and biotics metals
and other selection pressures that it's
really critical that we look at this
from an environmental perspective Thanks
next one is what are the advantages with
disadvantages of a meta genomic
monitoring approach for antimicrobial
resistance versus a targeted culture
based approach for example ecoli so for
sure culture based approaches are
valuable and traditionally that's how we
do microbiology right if we see it
growing in a petri dish we know that
that's a living organism and E coli and
other kolja forms have been very
valuable in water quality monitoring and
telling us if there's potentially
sources of fecal contamination and so
right there if you have fecal
contamination you have a problem you
likely have human pathogens and and
often antibiotic resistance kind of is
par for the course in those situations
and so a nice thing about a culture
based monitoring especially coli is most
labs are set up to do that
in the US and many parts of the world
that's core to our water quality
monitoring as these people pathogens and
so it's as simple as just adding some
antibiotics to the media so then you can
see whether these resistant bacteria are
there so it's accessible
but what I what I'm worried about is
that it doesn't provide you a microbe a
microbial ecological perspective so that
one organism is not necessarily
representative of what's going on in the
full microbial community not only might
there be other pathogens but even just
the resident natural flora could be
carrying a orgies and there's that
potential that they could be transferred
so especially in situations where we're
trying to understand which technologies
are effective barriers to the spread of
resistance we need to have a microbial
ecological perspective and most of those
organisms won't grow in a petri dish
now with the meta genomic approach we
can dig deep like I said ideally if we
have the resources we could get a
hundred percent of the genes and any
sample but it's gonna take some work to
develop the bioinformatics pipelines and
some consensus on what are the metrics
how do we harvest and interpret that
data in a meaningful way to represent
human health risk thank you can we have
time for just one more question what is
the confidence in the emetic impaired
approach and how might it be improved in
the future so the meta compare approach
is a first step and like I said it was
actually inspired by Jose Martinez's
group in Europe and basically makes the
assumption that the AR G's were most
concerned about are ones that are on
mobile elements and in pathogens but
there are other things that we could
consider as well so some AR G's encode
resistance to antibiotics that are
pretty commonplace and may be not last
resort or not even used anymore so we
could prioritize a orgies
that encode resistance to things like
think of my sin or carbapenems or
Calista and these are really important
black students or antibiotics we could
also tailor it to look at specific
groups of bacteria so right now we kind
of include everything that's out there
we look at the the perk database to
identify putative pathogens but you
could just look at specific subgroups
like maybe you're only interested in
Salmonella or Campylobacter it could be
tailored that way but you do also have
to think about confidence in assembly
so it requires M bleed of the
metagenomes to predict that the arg zara
mobile genetic elements and in pathogens
and we have pretty good confidence even
with short Illumina reads that an Arg is
on a mobile genetic element but it's
harder to save whether it's in a
pathogen because for example if a
plasmid is sequence you don't know who
the host is so that there is some
uncertainty there and so that's where I
think these technologies like nanopore
sequencing that give much longer reach
will really improve our confidence of
knowing that an energy really is an
immobilization well I would like to once
again thank dr. prudent for her
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December 13th 2018
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay we share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us we hope
to see you again soon bye